la choisi de se regrouper autour d'un
programme partagé et nous avons
construit en l'espace de trois semaines
un programme ambitieux de 650 mesure 8
chapitres chiffre est détaillé avec un
objectif que nous nous étions fixés
celui de gouverner le pays est de bâtir
une autre majorité il était prévu que
chacun ensuite se constituer en groupe à
l'assemblée vous avez raison ça se
démarquer presque en ressemblant vous
avez raison et je vais vous dire quelque
chose jusqu'à hier soir c'était toujours
notre intention c'est à dire avoir des
groupes parlementaires constitué comme
groupe ayant leur autonomie à
l'assemblée nationale les différentes
composantes la france insoumise le parti
socialiste le parti communiste français
europe ecologie les verts et avoir un
fonctionnement en intergroupe qui nous
permettent de traiter de manière
hebdomadaire tous les sujets communs de
l'action d'un gouvernement si nous
gouvernent ion ou de l'opposition qu'est
ce qui a changé ce qui a changé c'est ce
que personne n'avait prévu c'est le
nombre de siège du rassemblement
national et travaille donc une situation
politique qui est inédite et qui
nécessite que nous fassions la
démonstration du fait que nous sommes en
effet la première opposition en nombre
puisque nous avons quelques 150
parlementaires de la nouvelle union
populaire et qu'il n'est pas question de
laisser la main au rassemblement
national qui qui réussit cette élection
de quelques dizaines de députés dans que
c'est vous êtes assez transparent merci
vous dites voilà elle est fille devait
être la première force premier groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée toute façon à
contester on est 80 ils sont 89 ils
pourront
revendiquer d'être le groupe le plus
puissant il faut que nuque évidemment se
constituer en tant que gros vous tombez
dans des dans des considérations moi je
cite us à un autre niveau c'est de dire
à partir du monde il ya un fait
politique nouveau 90 estime d'être
intervenant mais non anticipée qui est
l'arrivée en nombre du rassemblement
national et on dira après qui en portent
la responsabilité si vous le voulez bien
pas juste faire des comptes et de la
comptabilité de deux sièges mais il faut
afficher puissamment notre union et donc
bien évidemment il ya d'autres moyens de
le faire on pourrait se dire bon on
reste comme on a prévu mais nous nous
pensons nous pensons et donc c'est une
proposition j'entends parler c'est quoi
la joie pour vous bah écoute et qu'elles
ont je lis a par exemple je vois que
emmanuel macron non seulement après la
déroute électorale qu'il a pris et le
fait que depuis cinq ans il a mis en
scène le rassemblement national il a
favorisé le rassemblement national pour
obtenir son
fonctionnement
dans le fonctionnement l'enjeu c'est que
depuis ce matin vous avez des
responsables de la macro ni je pense à
l'une des première d'entre elle madame
olivia grégoire porte-parole du
gouvernement qui vient expliquer sur les
plateaux de télé que eh bien oui
normalement la commission des finances
par exemple à l'assemblée revient à
l'opposition et que donc il est normal
qu'elle revienne au rassemblement
national mais s'est plaint au
rassemblement national s'il vous plaît
parce que la première force d'opposition
à cette assemblée tels que constituée
sous nos yeux c'est bien la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
qui n'est pas un coup de com nous ne
sommes pas réunis pour faire un tract
nous avons créé les conditions de
pouvoir gouverner ensemble donc l'idée
c'est bien qu'on nous soyons cette
première force à l'assemblée c'est
intéressant et donc attendait parce que
sur la commission des finances est un
peu technique est compliqué bien que les
chaînes parlementaires connaissent mais
pourquoi il revient de droit à la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale selon la tradition le poste de
la présidence de la commission des
finances pourquoi traditionnellement les
commissaires aux finances vote entre eux
au sein de la commission pour élire leur
président est traditionnellement ce
poste revient à l'opposition raison pour
laquelle normalement la majorité ne
participe pas si la reine a plus de
députés que vous non c'est là vous vous
gagnerez vous gagnerez manama je
m'explique non mais justement vous est
pardon pardon vous dire que là à
l'instant vous expliquer mal et que vous
gagneriez peut-être à écouter le mon
raisonnement jusqu'au bout vous êtes
dans la commission des finances en parle
ça mais c'est pas une leçon j'essaie de
11 cliquez je veux m'assurer que tout le
monde comprenne y compris vous dans la
commission attendant la commission dans
la commission des finances d'accord vous
avez la proportion est reine vous avez
les différentes composantes de la
nouvelle union populaire vous convenez
que au sein de cette commission la
nouvelle union populaire sera plus
nombreuse que le rassemblement national
sommes nous d'accord
oui mais voilà vous aviez dit le sauf
que là notamment que la nuque candidats
colin la nuit pour un derrière ce poste
alors je voulais pas qu'on a compris je
compris simplement pardon est ce que les
autres partis qui vous ont dit non tout
sinon à quoi
pour un candidat la commission ils sont
pas d'accord pour que la nuque en tant
que tel constituent un groupe dans
lequel finalement les parties
renonceraient à leur étiquette ses seins
pour la difficulté c est ce qu'ils sont
ce qu'ils peuvent se fondre dans la
nuque en tant que groupe à l'assemblée
ils ont dit non très franchement d'avoir
voulu utilisons dit non j'observe que
certains ont dit non mais vous voyez y
compris qu'au sein de ces différentes
organisations certains responsables
aient compris des élus depuis hier soir
ont affiché l'idée que c'était une bonne
idée moi je veux rassurer tout le monde
non attendez vous avait prévenus ou pas
j'ai pas très bien compris mais c'est
une proposition
avant que jean luc mélenchon est la
preuve mélenchon tout à l'heure on a
discuté avec nous arriver au siège il
est interrogé par vos collègues qui se
trouvaient devant le siège ils formulent
une proposition je veux dire tout de
suite les grands mots la nuque se divise
nos
dix
paquets de crise passe normalement
depuis l'endroit où je me trouve je
m'adresse davantage aux gens qui nous
écoutent et aux auditeurs qu'aux états
majors politiques mais je veux rassurer
tout le monde sur le fait que pour nous
il n'est aucunement question de
dissoudre ou de fondre les organisations
de politique dans la nouvelle union
populaire c'est juste une miliciens
comment est-ce que elle serait ou
l'étiquette parce que si on avait pas de
groupe vous n'avez pas de moyens de
fonctionner vous dépendrez du bon
vouloir de nu poudenx règlement l'union
populaire elle appartient à toutes
celles et ceux qui la composent donc il
ya une personne vassalise quelqu'un je
veux dire là dedans non simplement ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer si on se dit en
effet je ne dis pas que cet acte est à
cette heure c'est une discussion nous
formulons proposition si on se dit que
c'est la meilleure manière de
fonctionner au sein de l'assemblée
nationale on pourrait très bien imaginer
que chacun garde la capacité à
fonctionner en délégation écologistes
socialistes commune c'est ce qu'a
proposé votre consoeur collaboratrice
lui matt hill panneaux on va le voir
d'ailleurs c'est assez explicite dans le
tweet d'ailleurs un appel provenant du
dews il faut trouver collectivement les
conditions je suis favorable à une
présidence tournante bien sûr de façon
ce cas pas d'hégémonie à la grogne du
groupe de la france insoumise et un
maintien des délégations par formation
politique c'est-à-dire délégation c'est
un peu comme ça se passe au parlement
européen vous savez il ya des groupes
par exemple la gauche de la gauche puis
à l'intérieur il ya plusieurs
composantes ce à peu près la même idée
mais c'est une proposition
d'organisation ce que je pense que je
voudrais entendre
n'abandonnez pas l'idée de convaincre
vos partenaires comme vous l'assurer
pour proform pour former la nuque
personnes aux soins hier mais se veut
aussi dire c'est que je comprends que
l'on demande ces élections il y ait
besoin de choses pour alimenter
médiatiquement mais ce que veut dire
c'est que on formule une proposition
d'organisation et tout de suite
j'entends parler de quoi de divisions au
sein de la nouvelle union donnant dans
tous les cas soyez rassurés je passe ça
vous rassure vous personnellement mais
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale fonctionnera de toute façon
comme nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale ce bloc de 150
parlementaires au moins au sein de
l'assemblée nationale alors après quelle
forme ça prendra est-ce qu'on arrivera à
convaincre nos partenaires parce que
nous pensons que ce serait la meilleure
forme d'organisation et que chacun
pourrait s'y retrouver voyez la preuve
dit la production de mathilde de
panneaux une présidence tournante de
délégation pour chacun le but n'est
d'écraser personne a le but est d'être
en réaction en prend à la hauteur des
événements face à un groupe du
rassemblement
jean luc mélenchon qui est toujours très
inventif créatif et tactique eh bien
c'est dit voilà comment on peut garder
effectivement la puissance de notre
force d'opposition notre dynamique je
comprends mais était ce la meilleure
façon je vous le demande parce que il
ressort et vous ressortez collectivement
l'objectif est pas complètement atteint
mais quand même presque 150 députés
c'est puissant c'est important ce qui
n'a pas de gâcher un peu la fête par une
proposition qui est immédiatement
rejetée par des partenaires qui en fait
votre 806 hier c'est une chance mans est
ce qu'il n'est pas allé trop vite c'est
une belle proposition il a une
proposition roger
positionnons mais ça c'est ça c'est le
temps de la vie médiatique où vous
considérez toujours dit qu'il n'était
pas obligé de la partie et bien dans ce
cas là vos collègues ne t'es pas obligé
de lui tendre le micro à ce moment là
bas mais demandez nouvelle légère mais
supporter que les toujours comptable de
sa rive l'avait dit en introduction de
votre émission nous avons sous les yeux
une situation politique inédite tout le
monde en convient va supporter qu'on
réfléchisse et compta tonnes sur la
meilleure manière de nous organiser pour
faire ce que nous avons à faire
désormais c'est à dire faire en sorte de
nous opposer au projet de monsieur
macron même si à cette heure il n'a pas
la majorité pour le mener à bien et puis
on en n'a pas encore dit un mot mais moi
je veux dire je pense d'abord à toutes
celles et ceux qui ont besoin de
l'augmentation du smic on n'a pas encore
parlé de fond mais a besoin juguler les
voir alors je l'assumé stamm traduire en
arriver là ces questions à parler du
fond mais pour clore ce chapitre est ce
vous n'abandonnez pas cette proposition
non soir non bien sûr et je vais mettre
nos partenaires si le montant de ce que
je comprends que c'est plutôt un gouffre
et me faire parler parce que je suis pas
sûr tout ça passionne les gens qui nous
regardent mais je veux faire comprendre
à nos partenaires que c'est une
proposition qu'elle se discute et que si
nous la posons dans la discussion
aujourd'hui c'est parce que la situation
de ce matin est nouvelle et notamment du
fait de la force du rassemblement
national et je me permets de le dire
pour faire aussi un peu de politique et
pas juste de la comptabilité dire aussi
que le rassemblement national à 90
députés à l'assemblée nationale c'est la
responsabilité d'emmanuel macron
[Musique]